critical oh oh
uh are you are you inspired
rain by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new
i am the new chest jesus
[Music]
um all right so moist critical is
playing the sicilian
which is what we saw him play as well
against ludwig
he is comfortable with this opening i
don't know if he prepared specifically
but it's always good
to stick to something you know right
definitely definitely if you stick to
something you know then
the opening is going to feel a lot more
comfortable and you're probably not
going to lose so much time in the
opening as well
typically the opening is the one thing
that the players have prepared and that
the players feel quite
quite comfortable with but if that
preparation sort of
doesn't go so well or they get surprised
or don't
like their position then that
psychologically it's very tough for the
players
we have knight takes d4 here then the
pawn on e5 is going to be hanging
so critical might actually be able to
win a pawn he can even take the knight
queen takes and queen takes e5 and trade
his queen off the board
um okay so he went for this instead and
the computer
just had a heart attack here what is
going
on move orders are always so difficult
you know what you want to do but you
just don't know
the exact order of how you're going to
do it
yeah and we know that at all levels but
he does play bishop a3
which the computer does not like
um and the computer doesn't like it do
you want to know what
crazy move this computer is smoking
tell me knight b5 knight b
nobody's gonna play knight b5 because
you can't take because the bishop on b7
is is hanging so
that that's all the computer lines i'm
gonna have to see for today
i had to check goes knight b5 now then i
think that
we can just shake his hand basically
that would be that would be an amazing
move to find by him yeah this is going
to be the touring test
um if i guess touring tests
proves that no it would prove that he's
a computer it would be the opposite of
it
um if dwight sees it sorry if rayne
wilson i really like the office that's
why i keep saying it i'm so sorry
um i totally get that
anyway i think most of most of most of
people just think of him as dwight
rook takes e5 is certainly the most
accurate move here
um and you know with reigns play so far
i would not be surprised at all if he
takes with the rook here
playing so well wow wow jinx yeah this
is
i mean he is a heavy hitter for sure
just a blunder
no wait protected by the queen i didn't
even notice
he's playing so well yeah yeah and it is
sad to hear
um you know kind of i
i think in his voice you can hear that
critical noise the position has been
really tough
he sounds a little bit defeated and now
rook takes c6 is gonna win the queen
um but hopefully hopefully he doesn't
give up because even if
this game isn't going his way he can
come back in the next one
definitely definitely that's the
important thing that he doesn't
uh that he doesn't give up with the next
game right do you do you think reign is
going to see rook takes e6 here
i think that ring can see almost
anything no he didn't see that oh
wow he is giving charlie another chance
here
um and what charlie can do now is trade
off queens and then develop
or give a queen for free
oh no
no oh my god
no i can't believe i just did that
oh no
oh whoops i was so focused on castling
oh
whoops uh-oh
well what advice would you give to
critical it seems like
he's not in his best form today i know
he's very capable and he can play much
better than he did
i think that he should just get over
this game like just sort of like they
just laugh at himself a little bit and
you know what happened and then
just say okay rain has won the first
game
but there's another game and if i win
that game then i mean it's it's one one
and we're taking it to the next
uh to next match so i think that he just
needs to focus on the next one after
this and not dwell too much about this
game
um maiden five well
i i don't think we're gonna see that but
rain wilson's position is unstoppable
now oh
and critical resigned yeah
well i i don't blame him the position
was very difficult
to save and he did give it his best i
really hope he's able to
shake off the bad feeling from this loss
and come back in the next game
so they're going to start the next game
now e4 d64
all right and also this is not to
um say anything against rain wilson
because we obviously want the best
player to win but it would be great to
see both players
you know being able to feel like they
were playing their best chess and they
weren't in their heads so that's what
we're hoping to see here
and critical is basically playing what
we teach
all opening all beginners to do in the
opening put your pawns in the center
develop your pieces and rain wilson is
playing a perk
which is a king's indian if it's against
a d4 and it's a very strategic
system to play so it could be very
uncomfortable if he hasn't studied it
too much yeah he played it really
quickly and confidently e6 looks like a
very strong move black cannot
take i mean he can take and bishop takes
with check
oh my god he just lost a piece that's a
piece
he's gonna lose the knight on g4
and then critical's king is still in the
center of the board but he should be
just
up a pure piece here he should be able
to just get his knight and castle as
well pretty
pretty nicely after that oh my gosh
i mean uh narediski's pep talks are
worth
their weight in gold okay something
really
powerful is going on here he just has to
retreat the bishop to any safe square
and he's gonna be okay
as long as he doesn't blitz this out
perfect
bishop e3 his position is just
much better now he's up a full piece
i i wonder what's happening because
you know rain i i i always get surprised
when i see rain
fall for these kinds of mistakes and
then i have to remember he's also
human and just because he is an
incredible player doesn't mean that
people don't slip up that's true
everybody slips up even the best of the
grandmasters sleep up
all the time so definitely yes the best
grandmasters and the best
assistants rayne wilson i'm glad you
ended up getting that management
position at the end
um oh gosh did i just give a spoiler
no i didn't okay back to the game um
oh queen of no maybe you cannot go
okay that was a little bit too fast by
me i think oh yeah
he he is he's playing very fast even
though he's not the one in time
pressure let's see what critical's
saying he just takes with the knight
but that's good for me i'm up quite a
bit so here
take take
simplification nice
very nice that's exactly what you should
go for
i'm hanging this but it's just a pawn
right now oh i could have just came i
could have just come right in
he did have checks oh my god oh my god i
could have just went right in relax
relax charlie
okay oh no oh my
god do we have mulligans in this
tournament this is a great position
oh he moved this queen
i could have just went straight in
oh no oh no
don't beat yourself up oh
charlie focus what are the odds that i
get away with this if i play this
will it bait him enough to take it
because this is me if i can get this in
here charlie
cause he can't block it if i can get him
here
oh no he can block right here but it's
still good i need him to stay here
actually
how do i get him to stay there how do i
get him to stay realize his time
situation maybe coming over here
he takes i mate i'm running alone
oh i just gave him an out too
[Music]
but now rain now rain's gonna go knight
c5 i can't believe rain didn't take that
[Music]
donya's actually smiling through the pc
right now
yep how do you play knight f6 it's just
unbelievable
um all right well we're we're back um
we're we're back okay so
look overnight
yes he's back
these players are they are they are they
friends
what's going on here is this for content
i have no idea but but it was going to
take on e6
too oh if he takes on e6
dania might forgive him dania might
forgive him if he takes on e6
g4 okay all right bring the queen out
that's fine
he has 25 seconds oh no he's
sure to not lose the brick in any way
with something like king h1
or queen c6 can you go back uh
nope he lost the rook um
oh you can go queen g2 or bishop or
bishop d5
no you're right bishop you know no queen
g2 and take the rook you're right i
don't know i suggested that ah
okay it is it is
um he can he should still fight here
though
it's just a clock situation it's not
over
oh no he's he's not looking at the clock
oh no
oh no go go go go go
six seconds come on just any move just
don't flag
uh now rainey is gonna play super fast
as well
game is going to give me a heart attack
me too oh wow is there a repetition now
if he wants to but it's not enough for
him because he needs to win
exactly he needs to win and uh there is
checkmate queen h3
i don't know if oh rain missed it rain
missed it you're chilling
escape he missed maiden one oh my gosh
all right well critical is i i mean
it's a wild game it's a very well game
okay it's going back
oh man oh boy we're gonna have to trade
i think
just run just run don't flag don't put
queen f3 no boat as gambits please
king's gotta run
yeah i think king h3 would be checkmate
with queen h1
yep good he saw it king g1 he's not
getting mated
unfortunately he's in a worse position
but at least he's not getting mated and
he knows that he can't go for a draw
you can tell that critical is turning
into a chess player because he's
spending half
his time beating himself up it's a very
classic chess player thing to do
i can't kiss everyone just do it
oh no now he's i guess it's a draw
because it's opposite colored bishops
but he has no more winning chances now
unless
he somehow tricks reign and gets his
pawn on a5 but he'll probably end up
i don't know let's see what happens what
do you think i think that
this is it looks like a draw but at the
same time i feel like i need to hold
i don't know different color bishop end
game here i don't know if it's gonna end
up in a draw anything can still happen
it's a dance of kings rain wilson and
moist critical
the two left in the ballroom the last
ones after everyone's left the stage who
will get the last dance that made no
sense
just like this game we're all confused
about everything
why not give me five no oh
that was a pawn that had to be no
[Music]
no no
oh no do we have a dania cam i really
want to see the daniel camp
i just i'm not saying it's funny when
donya mauls but can we see the dummy
what's he saying it is a draw
um still but the problem i was still
hoping maybe he'd win or something
okay draw offer by charlie the rain
should just take it
i mean rain should just take it wins the
match for him and it is a draw
drawn position but of course
i was still harboring some hopes that uh
perhaps
bishop blunder might happen
oh okay well i who do you think
would be sadder if he gets knocked out
critical or his coach i think
critical still i mean chas just feels so
somehow
personal in a way and you know you're
putting all your effort into one game
and obviously you get kind of sad when
you lose so i think it's it's going to
be
more critical but he's taking a while
like he's laughing
and smiling yeah all right well they
agreed
on the draw um which makes sense because
rain was winning and he's going to make
it
into the semi-finals now that he has
knocked critical
we are back we're joined by rain wilson
and
moist critical rain wilson
congratulations you are making
it to the semi-finals critical
oh oh uh
are you are you inspired rain
by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new
i am the new chess jesus
oh my gosh critical he's coming for your
game and your personality what do you
have to do
no he's gonna have to really commit to
it no showers for three days i gotta be
able to see the grease on the webcam
the white t-shirt as well the white
t-shirt as well yeah absolutely
well i tell you that was a
nerve-wracking man these games don't get
easier i was
stressed out in that second game man
moist critical had me against the ropes
the whole time
was all i could do and um i thought i
was gonna win on time but then he just
kind of kept playing
a speed game the whole last part and i
couldn't get him on time and
um he just played he played great i got
lucky
so i got lucky you accepted the draw i
was ready to just commit to make this
like dr strange and keep you in a time
loop all day so i'm glad that you uh
offered a draw
i couldn't see a way to victory was
there a way for me to win without that
last set up you guys
it's actually a theoretical draw when
you have opposite colored bishops even
if you're up
upon and i was actually gonna ask if you
guys have seen any of these kinds of end
games before
i've never seen one i i was just going
off pure raw
primal neanderthal instincts an absolute
disaster
he played a move i'd never seen before
and he rocked me he absol he had me
against the
against the lockers in the football room
there i mean i was getting
blasted with all these moves i've never
seen you are going to be going up
against
benji fishy in the semifinals he's been
one of the top performers i think he's
second by raiding right now how do you
feel your chances are especially with
your new hairstyle
well the hair the hair won't let me down
if i'm the new chest jesus
but um uh i don't know i haven't looked
at his games
honestly i need to um kind of look at
at his style of play and and get a
little get a little prepped there so
i don't know in a lot of ways you know
i'm just my own worst enemy
in this i don't know if you feel that
same way critical because i
just my nerves and i and then the nerves
and i can't
quite think straight i can't kind of
really think the way that i normally do
in like a 10 minute game on chess.com
where i'm kind of
way more like detached and analytical
and i'm able to kind of
see patterns a little better i'm just
kind of like
i stumble in a little sometimes i
impulsively move
when i shouldn't even though i'm not
under any kind of time rush i got six
minutes on the
clock and i'm like you know and just oh
yeah um
so i'm kind of my own worst enemy so i
want to just get
and this is that's a good good um this
is good character building
[Music]
you